but we're going to begin with breaking
news from Russia where the government
there claims that drones from Ukraine
tried to attack the Kremlin overnight as
you may know the Kremlin is in Moscow
that is hundreds of miles from a border
with Ukraine and a short time ago a
senior official in the president's
office of Ukraine said that his country
had nothing to do with this apparent
attack Charlie dagada is in danipro
Ukraine with more on these charges from
Russia
Russia has called it an assassination
attempt on President Vladimir Putin in a
statement saying an attempt to strike
the Kremlin residence of the president
of the Russian Federation with two
unmanned aerial vehicles or drones
unverified we stress unverified videos
posted on social media appear to show at
least one drone shot down over the
Kremlin overnight That official
statement continues as a result of
timely actions taken by the military and
special services with the use of radar
Warfare systems the vehicles were put
out of action we regard these actions as
a planned terrorist attack President
Putin was not harmed neither was anybody
else for that matter the Kremlin says
Russia reserves the right to take
retaliatory measures where and when it
sees fit key has so far denied any
responsibility for CBS mornings Charlie
dagada denipro Ukraine